wild waves thrashing Atlantic City's
Beach are a mere precursor to what could
be on its way gonna have a lot of water
damage that's definitely for sure you
can see how quickly it's coming up
already and everybody's anticipating a
lot of water you know what we're gonna
hope for the best that's all you know
what it's just a home just a house mercy
that's what we care about the hybrid
superstorm is set to bring what's been
called a life-threatening surge flood to
the mid-atlantic coast obviously all of
us across the country are concerned
about the potential impact of Hurricane
sandy this is a serious and big storm
and my first message is to all people
across the eastern seaboard mid-atlantic
going north that you need to take this
very seriously in the town of Freeport
on New York State's coast road began to
flood as sea water rose through the
sewage in Manhattan the subway has been
closed no trains or buses are running
and schools across the city will remain
shut the big fear with this storm is the
power of its search how far inland the
water might come and how hard it might
hit the lights of Manhattan where those
lower vulnerable areas have already been
evacuated the streets around Ground Zero
are deserted as people either leave or
take shelter indoors forecasts for a
large and dangerous storm surge is the
same as it was this morning earlier
today I signed an executive order for
the mandatory evacuation of homes and
businesses in zone a I can't stress
enough that this is for your own safety
and that if you refuse to evacuate
you're not only putting yourself at risk
but also the first responders who will
have to assist you in an emergency with
precautionary measures in place that's
very little anyone can do but sit and
wait Amanda Walker Sky News New York
you